all right we have we have phantom coming
in phantoms phantoms cow Chaplin and
Benny pergolas they say patroller
I would think pergola cuz it's a G right
pergola yeah
it's Jim Norton and Sam Roberts you can
follow us on Twitter at Jim and Sam show
hi guys there they are we in terminate
here determined you hate when people say
the Phantom's right you hate that is it
good but it does sound a little old old
man II like if somebody's like hey it's
the Phantom sounds like an old baseball
team or something like the old phantoms
of 1746 right yeah the boys from the
Phantom's have arrived some phantoms
yeah he said it was phantom I said no
it's phantoms
yeah it's good right now there's bunch
of names people can look up it's great
what did you think that like when you
decided to name the group phantoms like
the Phantom's is more natural well
that's actually what I think when we
first started like years and years ago
we were like we're gonna be Phantom is
it gonna be really cool right and then
around town everyone was like hey it's
the Phantom's you know like right we're
calling us that and then it that kind of
stuck but it's not that no no we just we
took the veil out we're like we're
making this our own everybody's doing
that now - yeah why doesn't well dead
mass has a five in his yeah it's weird
yeah no it's just bizarre deadmau5 I
think had it bus smell inside I'd love
to talk to him he's really nice dude and
he actually started taking the hat off
on stage so it didn't really make sense
like he performs at the time in and out
so why even have the thing he takes it
off he's like yes he's trying to get out
of the makeup cuz he probably sick and
tired of it yeah headache then cannot be
fun to perform and I don't I don't envy
him what's he look like he's a regular
guy totally yeah he's super yeah super
thin dude but he we've gambled with him
in Vegas before and he's just like he
puts $1,000 chips down 5,000 chips just
like five different things at the table
they actually stopped him from gay
at the wind yeah I've won two months yes
incredible the water will do that man
Gant that's weird the casinos if you win
I knew a guy who won like five million
he was like the top guy in a casino I
think at the Paris or another one and
they get X amount of money back from
them and then they just booted him felt
like enough that's really some money
back and we're done with you yeah
everyone's honor in Vegas if you're
losing your life saving they don't stop
you they won't know before you lose it
almost yeah we we've been going out
there shooting some stuff with Dillon
Francis also a deejay and we get put up
at the Wynn never win there at all just
like he always wins and he's like
getting paid from the hotel to play
there we are not getting paid from the
hotel always always a loss at the wind
how much do you lose that month we're
not we're not giant gamblers but like
you know $200 $400 you know six times a
month how is the wind I'm gonna say
something really old ladyish and
understandably if you both just walk out
but they have a marvelous buffet at the
Wynn yes you were busy gambling and
[ __ ] chicks and partying and didn't
get to the buffet I think their lives
are different than mine yeah the winners
cool they have like three different just
full-on
EDM clubs over there so it's always
always a weird time weird night
yeah have just brought many different
people back yeah it's been fun we're
checking out that buffet next time no I
don't know how I've missed that oh it's
[ __ ] great man all kidding aside boys
so what is the difference
I don't know much about like EDM which
differs between that and dubstep okay
it's all you ready able to break this
thing down
EDM is like the giant hat okay let's
call it the the NFL okay there's like
different teams different stuff
happening within it like what's a
dubstep would be like the Jets okay okay
and then you have like deep house music
basically EDM is the umbrella under wish
right the other I ran out of analogy
somehow it became sort of a derogatory
term though at some point
was like not EDM I'm Nadia pumping but
it's what makes sense I mean it is
electronic dance music it's an easy name
to give it I guess
have you guys ever done shows I
interviewed Steve Aoki it I asked me
about uh you know everybody says that he
just pre records his sets and just kind
of waves his hands in the air like
that's the criticism mother right and he
said that I don't do that
you know I definitely don't but he said
one of the reasons that he says he
doesn't is because it's not really when
you're good at it it's not that hard no
set so it'd be like just as easy to just
do it as to pre-record
or why not just do it well I mean if you
love every track let's say it's at 128
BPM and it's just four on the floor just
don't don't don't
you're just matching those two beats
together so unless you're doing like hip
hop into that which most of the shows
are it's all the same it is pretty just
like you know get it lined up and then
you can kind of move back and forth that
being said there's a talent to it but we
we don't really DJ like we'll do it time
to time but we play live that's our
thing we try to do it as live as
possible he throws cakes on PT puts on
like a whole show I've never seen him
live but we interviewed him two in the
morning yeah 10,000 people just [ __ ]
shows yeah shows a day yeah he's like an
animal made a lot they get in the
privates and then they're just able to
do like five shows a night New Year's is
like the the smash grab for all DJs
that's when you booked like five
different shows and just ride the coast
like ride midnight going down all the
way from just like New York to LA they
call that riding the coat wow you guys
will do a show what time do you start
like 6:00 yeah I mean we're playing in
Denver we're just doing a festival
that that night we're not we're not that
level yeah we're doing like [ __ ]
chainsmokers ten shows and now the whole
thing will do that like guys like tiësto
and him without yeah like it was it was
it two songs I think pretty much three
number one two songs on Spotify
like top ten yeah dream songs all year
all year yeah like two of the top ten
we're chainsmokers
they they killed it they they came out
with that song selfie originally
they were kind of like a joke to
everybody it's a goof song yeah right
and then they came back and actually had
these like major [ __ ] hits and yeah
it was it was crazy how that all went
down so when you guys say perform live
what are you not really DJing yeah like
we're playing keys I mean it's again
it's performing live in the electronic
music space there's only so much you can
do right now like you can bring out the
whole rack of everything but yes singing
yeah not just like pressing play so what
do you have so you have a track mm-hmm
and then but you've stripped it of
certain correct drums keyboards yeah
yeah a nice thing on a lot of the stuff
so we yeah are able to do that live just
elevated I mean look there's nothing
wrong with deejaying which it's not for
us to do I mean it would be [ __ ] hell
of a lot easier not drag gear and [ __ ]
right roll up with a USB stick get
wasted and then just leave so jealous
our friends that get to do that and make
twice as much money so they're guys well
I'm fasting but they should do a show
and then go right to the airport fly
somewhere go do another show yeah
meanwhile [ __ ] all kind of in the New
Year's Eve theme and do five a night
yeah yeah me and I yeah yeah Jesus
Christ he minded that's a tough night
because one one time you're delayed
because of weather your whole night is
[ __ ] yes that's why they're pre
recording their show the nice thing
about you know it makes sense to get a
private jet on nights like that and then
you just drive up to the the jet and
then you're out your graphic getting in
that I mean I'm thinking in New York but
just the traffic getting to the airport
but you everything right to just doing
it on a private jet I've thought of
doing that if I have shows maybe two
days apart one Thursday one on a
Saturday you know I'm a private just a
little above my price yeah yeah it is
nice though I mean we've only got to
like the [ __ ] tag-along guys on the
private jet they're opening bands in
that stuff we're opening actual you guys
open for an act like that
yeah it depends if it's a festival it's
just a bunch of random you know EDM
people put together but there's still
tours that go around like we're opening
for our friend Dylan he's sold out the
Shrine Auditorium three nights in a row
which is like 5,000 people yeah cap so
we're we're doing those shows coming up
which will be really fun that's amazing
yeah it'll be a good time
it's crazy he's got a very like EDM like
the fist pumpin crowd and we're a little
more a little more of a deep house vibe
yeah weird
what's different it's like one is look
every it's like big drops it's like the
very very high energy like that kind of
stuff and I was a little more like songs
like you can sort of flow into it a
little more that's not just like song
after song after song so it's definitely
a bit of a different vibe yeah you guys
are both you guys are both actors before
you did this right yep yeah child actors
back in the day LA yeah was that like
the gimmick you were like hey we're both
child actors we should start a band or
did you know H other we just knew each
other
actor but it was in pornography we both
like in the Disney scene grew up with
all those kids and we pretty much
[ __ ] hated it after a certain amount
of time everybody does right oh is it
yeah meet weirdos that are out there
like it's hard for me to look at like
some actor kids we know that aren't just
like crushing it yet or doing just like
some little show or something and
they're just so like they just feel like
they did something so good like they
just cured cancer or something I'm like
dude your does your number like guess
number three on Teen Wolf like that's
not that big I don't know like that's
cool that's fine it's but they haven't
gone on to actually create anything
you're saying yes yeah I mean some have
we we know a couple of people that have
gotten successful on there but yet for
the most part those kids are they're a
bunch of weirdos
what's the first like after you have
like a child success of your show when
does it become like oh no I did this is
ending like at what point is it like
when you're 12 years older you start to
see like there's something changing your
mom's lessons crisis yeah we watch that
a lot I mean a lot of our friends were
on really successful shows and they were
like on top of the [ __ ] world for for
their you know teenage years it's like
the the best you know like the popular
kid in high school but on a huge level
and then I think like once the show ends
the couple years after that is kind of
hard to watch like they're going through
the ringer there it's like to watch
people like that's got us that's why a
lot of them wind up with drugs or [ __ ]
up
oh yeah he's gotta be depressing party a
little too much now too late getting a
little too drunk and you're like okay
they're going through something right
now and then some people would really go
off into that zone
yeah some people would I think kind of
transition out of it I mean imagine like
Disney is basically your parents because
their parents didn't give a [ __ ] what
they did right especially when you're
plucked out of this small town and like
you're kind of the moneymaker and you're
a kid in the house like how do you
listen to your parents when they're like
don't go out tonight really I'm paying
I'm paying the mortgage here so I'm
gonna do whatever the [ __ ] yeah you stay
so that just creates a weird I think
like mental space for a kid growing up
either you guys oh no we know that much
we were not that successful I always
wonder like I feel like the kids that
are on those shows start to grow up and
you always if the show is successful
like it lasts a little longer for the
kids than it should and I always watch
like like like like you hear from the
people in later seasons of shows that
all have to realize that it's like it's
not funny to them anymore like the show
is terrible now to them yeah because
they've aged past the group that is
ending yeah good friends is a
Christopher mintz-plasse who's McLovin
from Superbad but he gets that all the
time and it's gotta be annoying and I
you know it's such a big role and it was
great it kind of started his career but
there are times at the airport it's just
like dude man what's and it's just like
gotta be teenager anymore yeah and just
like when you're when you're just out
and like doing your thing just to be
called McLovin all the time it's got a
it's gotta be annoying yeah you gotta
try to just do thanks man appreciate
right get out of that situation that's
how great to get a role like that but
also at the same time you kind of want
to get that flying to the radar room yes
some people will be on like I'm a big
enough French elephant that's most of us
on a Mouseketeer and then but she was 60
and people still know who she was some
people just make a life out of a child
accomplishments and some yeah luckily
for her nobody knows who she is anymore
for the cello heads turn well Charlie
and famous Mouseketeers child star there
was Britney I think was one resident
ever like there's a bunch of that went
on to uh Miley Wade Miley Cyrus she was
at Disney Store in Hannah Montana
yeah this guy I'm on time with her and
yeah I was on like the very first or
second episode ever of that show so it's
funny to watch it go from like you know
just her being this girl - then Miley
Cyrus kind of happening after the fact
but I gotta say she was the most normal
there she is she was the most normal out
of I think all the child actresses that
we knew she liked she kind of you know
obviously rebelled like a little bit
later on but I think she did in a
healthy way like just being a kid like
just doing her doing her thing you know
right wearing latex underwear and [ __ ]
yeah hey you know what we all act out in
certain ways I mean right now
I would certainly wear them they make
your hog look great don't they I guess
I'm out of this one guys talk amongst
yourselves any type of Underpants that
makes your [ __ ] package look good you
gotta support oh yeah it's all smoke and
mirrors parlor tricks in your pants are
you guys are doing a gig in New York we
actually just did yeah we sold out
babies all right in Brooklyn which was
really fun it's like just it's one of
those Brooklyn spots well there's like a
deejay at brunch kind of thing like
Brian and the venue's in the back so was
it right I was feeling about that but it
was great though like the crowd was
awesome and so that I laid two so bad
crowd for you like yeah just not moving
or there's yeah the people that are just
standing there like looking at you as if
you're just hair's on fire kind of like
that the entire time and just a a lot of
like the arms crossed like that that
should like for us when like everybody's
into it we just feed off of that and
it's a lot more fun for us but other
than that yet they're just like looking
that right it sucks
have you guys done like I hear when you
tour overseas like places like Japan
where culturally it's kind of polite for
them to sit there that's got a suck in
your line of work if they're just kind
of sitting it up oh yeah totally
respectful yeah respect we had we've
realized too that people like have
different ways of enjoying shows like
not everyone's gonna be jumping around
but there was one time in Minneapolis it
was just Duke reeling me the entire time
he was grilling me looking at me and I
was just like of us like couldn't stop
or like this [ __ ] guy yeah I'm gonna
come after the show more kill display
yeah it's just like so pissed in my head
as I'm doing my thing and then after the
show he's linked to you that was the
best show I've ever seen man you're just
like okay it's so crazy sometimes you
think somebody hates you and they don't
it's like that for them it's the
experience is happening in their own way
and they're loving it
right yeah it's absolutely hard to tell
what are they feeling right now why do
they hate me and then they're like dude
that was so much fun yeah yeah and then
maybe they were just enjoying it like
not just not even in the moment just
like Ian for some reason in their own
way right just like sitting there like
just taking everything in yeah they're
not reacting to anything which like does
that does that happen in comedy too like
it stand up so it only happens to people
quietly enjoy assuming yeah yeah they
never said that's the best experience of
my life but I leave quick so everybody
must really just be taking it all in
yeah well it really drank really fine
wine so did you guys like were you
overacting or did acting kind of dry up
and you were like we got to figure out
the next thing it's like a mix of both
yeah I was on 10 Things I Hate About You
like the TV show remake that I think
five people watched totally and then on
the show I actually came out of the
closet like the character came out of
the closet and then the show got
cancelled so it's like the gay community
is like dude we do not want you in here
and then after that yeah audition after
audition game your life on the show on
the show oh yeah no and uh in real life
I'm not but hey on the show I was and
there's a beautiful beautiful thing
harder to play a character who comes out
as he barely got a chance to they can't
yeah I mean you might have to do a scene
you don't want to do like if you're it's
like yeah I mean that show wasn't like
this is kind of before it was like a big
thing that come out on a show then we're
now it's like it shouldn't even be that
big of a thing that wasn't five years
ago it was like no it's not that long
ago yeah it was like it was like more of
a thing and but they were so I think
afraid that even doing that was like a
big moment for them so it's before 2016
where you have to like just go full-on
make out with the dude on there like
right kind of stuff which is kind of
like you're not even to assume a
character is straight until it's spelled
out for don't assign a gender identity
yeah yeah there's a lot of that
happening right now we're just like
cisgender man I just don't understand
how very it's kind of diluted it's very
hard to understand I'm pitching a scene
between where I get to make out with
Newt Gingrich I just I know I'm not
attractive who I just want to do it I
think Polly would by storm you know
Jenner
- Oh first you can't just pitch that is
the show everyone would imagine we did a
pay-per-view where Newt Gingrich's make
out for 20 minutes no talking just
holding each other's faces and kissing
and all the money goes to charity I
would buy it I think we just found our
plan let's do this yeah yeah we'll be
there we'll million music oh yeah the
balls in your court Newt
yep you guys knows nude nude do it shows
for you guys it's gotta be an incredible
like it's just the DJ's [ __ ] dude
really mop up as we say yeah DJ's like
people that have the DJ vibe but can
actually sing and play instruments yeah
no it's awesome I mean so when were like
when we finish the show like we have
this like pocket of time which is like
you go to talk to a girl but we also
have to low down get the [ __ ] out of the
venue's so the industry calls it [ __ ]
time right yeah exactly
what kind of [ __ ] time do we have a very
slim / a phantom show yeah because we
have like no time so you try to go out
there and it's like make it work and you
try to like get the [ __ ] down with the
venue's you can bring it back to the
hotel isn't like that you should end
your shows earlier just have like the
allocated time or we have security move
all the dudes out of there it's great we
do better actually when we go to our
friend shows because then we don't have
to do anything and we could focus on it
too like when Dylan's playing in Vegas
he's we're just out there drinking and
like bringing girls up on the stage and
just good to do it oh you still get to
be on stage oh yeah yeah yeah so even if
they don't know that you're performers
they know that you get to be on stage
that's a very important thing to be on
for instance no I'm trying to figure out
how to weasel my way into some [ __ ]
EDM talk about we'll just say you're
marshmallow he's another duty wears a
marshmallow on his head biggest thing
ever
yes a look at my body in a balloon
where's the suit everywhere huh yeah
who's home who's marshmallow I don't
know Marshall on he's Mars like the new
deadmau5 with a new he has not taken the
hat off yet yeah pull up a picture of
this guy he um he's absolutely crushing
it right now I don't really like it I
don't really understand it it's um he's
got a whole thing it's a marshmallow way
dresses like a Marshburn kids the kids
love him like the really young EDM kids
that are just getting into it like yeah
I get the entropy low that's somebody
the could be kissed in the 70s had that
Miss mystique about them and if you
don't know what these guys look like
especially now with all these [ __ ]
cell phones and social media I can see
where that would be really interesting
and yeah enticing yeah yeah I think
that's the like Banksy yeah exactly yeah
the mysteries half the appeal exactly I
mean Banksy was able to make a whole
career it was just like I think getting
that art out there without the identity
yeah do you think that if he came out
and people knew who he was he would be
less appealed to him um I think I'll
eventually do that because I think all
those guys eventually want to get that
kind of he's gonna have to same yeah
just you know like I think when you stay
behind for so long it's got to be maybe
kind of nice to go on the street and
people not know you but also I think you
also get annoyed by that - maybe and
also like if you don't ever take the
thing off you could sell to gimmick to
somebody else
a gimmick out to somebody else and you
need to go on the road that's what they
say about that funk they say that that
funk when they went on tour it was just
like the brand-new people doing it up
there yeah you've never don't rent it
out to somebody else he um he did some
of the interesting news in New York when
bang she was in New York he had those
his own pictures set up and that he
didn't sign or he signed them small in
the back and he had some guys selling
them on support less and he was saying
basically this is what the name does
because if you just put the art out
there a few people bought it no one gave
a [ __ ] right it's all there were
thousands really Fame he was just saying
like my name doesn't mean much either
it's just my name means more than my art
and by the way nobody took anything from
that cuz everybody was like immediately
yeah I'll pay tens of thousands of
dollars we knew that they were Banksy's
cuz I would've went over there import a
whole bunch of them Oh Travis right how
much 60 bucks she's like just just
street art if you'd known it was Banksy
you would have bought more than one
three or four even know what they got a
cool picture mouse that they just have
he told at least one of his friends
going by for yeah because there's good
there going it's my stuff I bet he told
at least one person because one guy
bought four pictures I'd hope so I mean
I'd be kind of annoyed if it's like dude
can I finally get a piece of your art I
can okay cool tell me where and when
you're like let me that's really hooking
a friend up that would be nice
I did whose podcast the easy aegeon
artist show oh my god - oh yeah I did
his bike oh yeah and I used to do with
asa akira and for asking have you seen
him and he's supposed to give me like a
little piece of art afterward and he
never gave me one was bummed out - you
know I liked him - he's really good yeah
I remember that was this thing was like
a little piece of art afterwards he
didn't get it to you what was that about
I don't know I think yeah busy yeah
other things I know he's very wounded
one of my little art have a nice to hang
up I don't own any art from oh no I I
did a gig recently and some guy gave me
this cool thing in Florida he people he
does bacon art he's out of his mind okay
there's all this stuff with bacon sorry
sent a whole bunch of this stuff to the
studio did he really set me up with this
one that was Tommy Chong it was [ __ ]
great
yeah I'm gonna hang it up yeah alright
yeah good Tommy Chong no no it's a
painting but he puts bacon in it um the
the the one about bacon dancing I
probably wouldn't bet this a little
weird but this one was just a picture of
Tommy Channel I like the colors a lot
that's be John covered in bacon I like
it I'm smoking bacon or something bacon
yeah I'll stop saying bacon is there it
throw in the interview I apologize do
you get girls at all based off the kid
shows that you were on are you too young
does it does any Milly can you use that
later on like hey you grew up watching
this show there might be some like kid
that's maybe a little like holding on to
the past maybe some weird daddy issues
where maybe something could kind of work
but now for the most part it's just like
that and snapchat has actually been a
big thing oh yeah they got snapchat
right yeah I just um we started kind of
doing these stories and using it as more
of like a like a through-line and do
these weird videos on there and it just
kind of took off it's actually helped
everything
a bunch because it adds kind of a little
more personality to the project too and
even though right now it's like 9:00 in
the morning and we're pretty hungover
what do you do I check so we'll just do
like random little things it can just be
like 1 1 we're all gonna Vegas together
I actually did take a flight to Seattle
and then to Vegas just for the sheer
joke cuz as a geolocation tag we
literally did we committed to this joke
for me to actually go to yeah just to
show Kyle going to the wrong City yeah I
went to the wrong City and I'm like
they're having the best time in Vegas
getting like champagne girls and [ __ ]
I'm just stuck flying like how the
flight attendant a like I sort of the
only seat available to go to Vegas is
like a four thousand dollar upgrade in
first-class it's like so much it yeah
that's got to be kind of a nice place to
be when you can buy extra plane tickets
for a snapchat joke geolocation you
could have just lied yeah I would a lie
I would've been in McCarran Airport
going ah boy I hate Seattle where I got
to in Seattle go to the girl in
Starbucks and just go like hey what city
am I in and she's like I was in Las
Vegas right now and she's saying sure
you're in Seattle partners in Las Vegas
yeah I'm in Seattle you missed the gig
remade it
oh no we made it yeah yeah we did that
on yeah I was it was planned out on
purpose but we started the whole thing
so these kids watch it and you know I'm
like a hundred thousand people it's like
a small like local cable channel that we
kind of get to do ourselves by just
having these kids it's pretty amazing
how do you know how many watch it does
isn't it hard to see how many followers
you on snapchat you can't see exactly
how many followers are on there but you
can see how many views so like if you
have something that's been up there for
like a full day and you're posting you
can kind of get a good idea about where
you're at but yeah they got a view count
if you click it and yeah look at it I'm
trying to work with a snapshot a little
bit I don't do any snaps I just look at
them yeah yeah dude it's the weirdest
like interface it's really hard to get
used to and use it but it's also kind of
embarrassing to shoot them because you
just feel like a tool holding up your
day and walking around and like well
we'll shoot them in front of people that
like love our snaps and watch them all
the time and then when we shoot them
they're like making fun
of us like because it's like it you know
guys guys we are yeah the whole thing
how many do you do a date like you don't
want to over kill it or do you just do
as many as you want just kind of do when
we when we feel like it yeah like we did
one yesterday we just had like a press
day around and this the whole joke was
every meeting we went into we just sat
down and got right back up and just
laughed and said sorry guys I don't have
any time for this we're busy and just
did like a whole stupid story like that
yesterday so just be kind of like man
but you do it over the course of many
videos yeah yeah cool so if I shoot this
and then just put it up I'll just go up
a snapchat hey yeah
why don't you you want to help Jim and
get it on no get it on our snapchat too
both at Jim and Sam sure so we can watch
wait I'm snapchatting yeah this is great
what a hot moment this is a hot moment I
like you guys like you kind of tried to
turn it on just now for snapchat cuz
you're like yeah snapchats our thing but
Jim was just giving you nothing to my
story yeah you okay looking great Ian
okay we got the double angle on that oh
we viral viral yeah guys huffington post
is posted about this is great
yes mate we did it we did it Congrats
that's amazing yeah so we always feel
like PS are you always feel like because
it goes away and it's such a weird thing
you get used to it just evaporating yeah
and not like with Twitter you can go
back Facebook you can check it but we're
just think of it going away that's the
nice thing about it really yes if you
make stupid [ __ ] it just goes away yeah
and then when we come through with like
some just like pretty c-level content
that's not gonna get stripped down and
added to the best stuff on YouTube yeah
exactly
kids actually make reels of that stuff
and put it up I've seen it yeah can you
save your own story stuff I don't know
how to do yeah oh it's a little download
but look at that smiley picture yeah I
have a lot of good smile okay but I have
to be careful to open in front of people
yeah yeah a lot of creepy things might
pop up yeah well that's what snapchat
was originally designed to do to send
send pigs back and forth but so many
people [ __ ] up and they think that you
can't save it and there's ways to hack
all that stuff it doesn't disappear
yeah but also that just happened with
what's-his-name from Golden State
Warriors he just had that come out
already sent out traffic not Travis that
it was uh right here are some Barnes I
think he came out and like took a
picture of uh something happened where
his dick went on the internet because of
that because a snapchat is a big dick or
small dick I didn't look at the dick
long enough to remember don't remember
the dick but it was uh I'm only asking
that because what did he do it on
purpose or by mistake right like right
if it's a small like Brett Favre's dick
with a dumb [ __ ] jelly shoe that was
a mistake
terrible angle [ __ ] [ __ ] palsy
that was a bad photo but if you a giant
dick you know winds up on the internet
it's ago a terrible mistake yeah is he
single or no I'm not asking like I want
to meet him I'm sending it out
absolutely opposed to do a story and I
think he was trying to send it to some
girls
oh yeah that's an easy mistake there
right yeah some difference but and
that's probably was a mistake too
because you get you know this kids
following you or there's [ __ ] fifteen
year olds following your snapchat you
don't put your dick out there I like it
when celebrities accidentally tweet
their phone numbers it happens more
often than it of course it's way more
often than it should be I mean they're
trying to DM their phone number and they
just tweeted that to everybody people
ignore it never and know it's time for
the celebrity to get a new phone and
that actually happened a DJ snake is
another DJ there's that Ultra Music
Festival which is like the biggest
festival in Miami he put up our friend
Dillon's number in front of the crowd
and it was just like the amount of texts
and calls that came in on purpose and
then we did that to our friend forest on
a snapchat and put his number up there
and it was just non-stop
I'd be so annoyed if somebody did that
to me yeah it's kind of a [ __ ] up joke
but it was I don't even know why we did
that I think we were just being yeah
they were just being bored and funny
though and it's not your phone number
it's funny it was a one time we didn't
fly and we was just traffic and we're
just like why don't we just send Forest
number out and just watch his phone
blow-up forget it I think we say there's
a good idea going on about like
like tell him he's a bad photographer so
like all these calls were coming in like
hey boys [ __ ] you you're bad have you
ever tried to do relationships while you
were in the band yeah I mean yeah I'm in
one I'm in one now which is why thank
God how long is it it's been it's been
like six months now like it's no serious
yeah it's new but um I never planned on
that at all it was it was always like
that's that's gonna be a difficult thing
to sorry no you're good no it was just
like it just happened pretty naturally I
mean she's a [ __ ] awesome chick and I
was like you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
try this I'm gonna make this one work I
think she just like a civilian girl I
hate using the word civilian yes don't
need to you're not the military
I know celebrity person yeah pretty much
just she's a regular girl she's really
good and she's awesome but it's actually
what's up for me cuz he's like the the
face of the group and now that he's gone
I'm just out there just being like
tinder up Riya fumble all the app
getting out there sending out tinder has
this thing where you can put your
location before you get there well it's
a game-changer because you can kind of
go like hey I'm in town playing a show
like I don't know what's going on in the
city and then you're just able to like
get this lined up come to the show watch
it just full scumbag yeah there's no
competition it's it works great but
don't you get like doesn't it seem like
your band mate is having like a lot of
fun oh yeah I mean it's it's it's good
to see though it makes me happy to am on
Ryan I've talked about yeah
I've talked to a bunch of girls but none
not many have come to fruition is that
right
yeah that I do a joke him act about a
girl googling me and it was actually
from Ryan not from tinder where should I
google Joe well Ryan knows Ryan's the
one that like it to be invited to right
yeah yeah like a it's like all model
girls and my best girls on earth they're
[ __ ] so on yeah they also have
probably a better selection than like
tinder because yeah to meet like the DJs
basically yeah comedians yeah no it's
funny it's a place for a model to
politely chat with comedians and never
follow through
option B say hello and that's it well I
saw I talked to my girl last night
actually I've been trying to meet up
with her this whole trip and I we ended
up it was like kind of last night here
so we had way too much to drink last
night you know of course had to be up in
the morning great idea price buy I like
Texas girl my room number and I passed
out and I woke up to a bunch of texts
Amuro she's like I'm coming with a
friend right now like she actually was
bringing a girl with I [ __ ] fell
asleep she was so pissed she got to the
hotel that would've been a threesome
yeah that would've been the threesome
right there oh my it just would have
happened but you fell asleep what
happened it was it was done I was done
the guy's a I'm terrible I have the same
thing happen except it's me continually
texting room 705 I'll actually write it
and I spell it out did you get that last
text everyone through or not lol you
know keep it like III used to use Bob
write like Raya once you go to riots
really humble stinks ladies go first
what all this [ __ ] stuff and how
gender isn't important but the lady has
to go first yeah yeah it's it's uh I
mean which is kind of refreshing you
don't have to like start off with some
stupid vine like hell they never say hi
to me rather store for the cheesy line
and take my chances what's your opener
Riya what are you going with what up
babe I don't know Maya find opening all
right it's a good question yeah yeah and
while he's looking for that I would
imagine that somebody who can just like
kind of come in here and joke like if I
knew that I missed a threesome cuz I
fell asleep like this there be broken
things in the studio I'd be so obsessed
yeah but that's because I brought you I
would imagine you've you've had
threesomes before I've had a semi
threesome where it didn't escalate into
full-on
like just sex breaking out everywhere
I'm like like a cooking up threesome but
never got past that level got your toe
in the water you're gonna have to dive
in soon yeah last night was gonna be the
night but it was a whole thing guys I'm
not stoked about I feel like that's your
rock bottom you need to sober up okay I
say hello to one hit just hello with
with whatever her name is
and they respond yeah and then that's an
honest way of doing it yeah hi
hello hi so-and-so how are you yeah what
else you gonna say I like to open with
we like to laugh sometimes I try that it
doesn't work believe it I've tried to be
intriguing by being odd it doesn't work
try to be quirky we tried that going
into a picture with like a handsome
friend and both of you were in there so
you get the like at first there and then
he knows it go through the pictures they
realize like oh that's actually me I
know I've got it with uglier friends and
they're still disappointed so what kind
of weird [ __ ] do you do I'm trying to
look it's trying to see these lines I
say a lot of like bonsoir
just like good night always just for no
reason at all but there's um there's
this I feel like there's some weird ones
oh here's one one who said she was in a
photographer I wrote hey nice to meet
you what kind of photography do you do
so what else he's supposed to ask about
something that they put it's just so
funny like it's just that you dig a
seating yeah yeah hostel yeah another
thing to like with these that we had we
had a friend you know if mo is yes venmo
or mmmm we'll pay ya what do I could you
guys smarten me up yeah so venmo is
pretty much it's like a pal or something
looks like an app it's a little more
like a social media that you can look at
kind of everything and like you can like
people's things it's like tacos last
night drunk $20 you can like it and just
have leave your mindless social media
life doing that but but why do you give
him $20 no I mean I'm just you can you
can like any amount of money so like
what you giving him money for just way
so instead of like going to the
restaurant and then we like you know
need to all divided up would you get
I'll get this on the commercial yeah
great time you can only do a there's a
certain amount you can do before you
have to like there's a limit per day
I've tried venmo or something but you
don't always want to use your name I'm
glad you any time we've gone out to
dinner I'm pretty sure every time you've
picked up the checking we've never split
that's for sure
no do you do that with other people like
why do you I know I always pick up the
check so what do you need my man what do
you mean venmo for okay somebody might
need some extra spending money
we pocket money you know I haven't right
good point there was this really scummy
way to just like be an [ __ ] in there
and it's just like find a girl's number
like get that you just text her a
hundred dollars like venmo and just put
what up that's it just give her money
yeah just like a hundred dollars what up
because you gotta see like what the
response is gonna be is she gonna take
the money and she's not is she declined
the money you know have you gotten money
declined
I'm never but it's your name you send it
if you fine if you just want to use
those you're so you start like you just
find a girl's picture on venmo and send
her money no usually you have to know a
little something before I am not sure I
mean this this was tried one so this was
drunk and I was actually pissed that I
sent uh hundred all this did not pan out
she was like thank you polite exactly
Ben Moe is a boy filaments two hundred
dollars a day or something into your
consent more until you verified Western
Union to go on to when they're not
[ __ ] up that I have that app on my
phone in case of Franklin was like I
thought I thought it was one of those
places where it's like you know Western
Union you know send me like eight
thousand dollars will send you back five
thousand like I thought it was just like
used for scams no they have the worst
customer service in history because are
all in the Philippines it was hard to
understand but if a friend rolls a flat
or something it's easy for you to do it
yeah you do that and you send them the
tracking number and all as well
good different countries that works into
is that right sure does give a lot of
international friend you bet I do
okay that's great we should all just
send each other money you know random
about and see what happens I guess I
just don't have I don't have
international friends like that I don't
wear it or American ones have you
sitting there looking at the app like I
got nobody to send money to yeah Dana
it's dangerous how easy it is to send
money these days or how how fast you can
get caught up in those crazy totally
anything stations even even like the in
app like the games they have on the
Apple phone oh yeah yeah these kids are
racking up like 100 200 dollars like
tabs on their parents credit cards
because they're just buying the [ __ ] and
those yeah it's mind-blowing they're
meant just to get people like addicted
to buying
but [ __ ] that's really cheap yeah right
slow in $10,000 on Cubert but I guess
it's not that different for like in the
old arcade games a lot of times you have
to put in another quarter to get to
another level or stuff I was like a
quarter but they would literally have
$100 for like you know buy the max
amount of coins 100 bucks that's true
yeah that's a good point we used to play
I used to play that at the Simpsons game
uh-huh on the iPad where like you you'd
build the neighborhood or whatever Oh
what were you killed your ex-wife that
sounds like one of those games that were
eats like yep usually old [ __ ] and it
involves it's like whoo you need more
coins or you could just spend like you
know twelve hours waiting or something
play the game without buying the [ __ ] is
like not nearly as fun you can do cool
[ __ ] yeah and it takes forever and
they're like don't you want Krusty the
Klown it's only a hundred doughnuts oh
how do I get doughnuts yeah well you'll
get one every six hours or you can just
buy a bunch 20 bucks on this time again
and later you build so much sorry I
would spend I would spend more than that
if it were a game in a store it was like
60 bucks for a Playstation and you spent
$700 really today and I mean that's what
happened with Pokemon go like that the
whole thing was such a [ __ ] thing
when it first came out and had everybody
addicted to it and people were just
spending so much money on this game and
then this is a game that now like I
think everybody doesn't play anymore I
get this top-down did it go away I think
children still play it where it was
intended to be for children and I think
it does have given it up and going like
we here it is you're in the dork if you
still play pokemon it lasts for a few
much Travis you still play he does yeah
I played my daughter like I finished a
long time ago right I'll play with her
so how long did it last
you gotta do that's how you treat a lady
wait a second he's a gentleman just a
long time ago but I still play with her
[Music]
most dad's are done too soon I have to
wipe my backlog oh my god well listen
guys he's a great man yeah you guys a
lot of fun thank you thank you a PHA and
tio period MS fan towed on Twitter do
you to buy it for somebody no we got
that we got it pretty much everywhere
but Facebook and there's some I think
bookshop that's called like phantom
folks that do not want to give up their
domain and the domain I think is still
out of looks like you know early 2000s
where it just looks old and were just
the guys we just please have that so I
think we're stuck with phantomjs clean
yeah or something like job how about the
Phantom's tube and that's yeah I mean
that's a around something you can how
about phantoms on snapchat phantoms yeah
but you're phantoms on snapchat as well
yeah yeah phantoms on snapchat phantoms
on Twitter everything like that so
alright cool man well thanks for
stopping by we have one of yours which
song are we playing do we know in the
name of the song I knew and someone to
talk about someone to talk about yeah
I'm Kyle and Vinnie thank you guys and
anytime you want to come back come back
I'd love to appreciate thank you guys